rich where did you watch the michigan
ohio state game at that home with Susie
and the kids just that's it my phone I
put my phone away Dan Wow not to be
trusted but I knew it too and I knew I
knew the reason why I set it on on the
show last week and because i knew the
big 10 refs had a coup de Gras coming
and I didn't want to tweet about it or
text about it or do anything stupid and
sure enough they had something nice and
cooked up but I will tell you this i
agree with you and i will say it all the
time rod woodson told me that the chuck
noll would always tell the steelers this
before going out on the field play
better than the rest ref and when it all
comes down to it the turnovers been the
mistakes allowed them aloud Michigan to
have the door open for for some of these
penalties to not be called or be called
and and that's part of the reason why
they got two losses right now what do
you make of horrible after the game I
don't blame him I feel the same way I
feel the same way and I know that he's
going to be criticized for whining
complaining Ivan you know I heard the
show open for you as you know I listen
to your show going to work every day
like most of us here in Los Angeles and
um you know that that's part of the
criticism but he's only giving voice to
what a lot of us feel and it happens all
the time I mean I'm serious the Big Ten
is a major problem with its officiating
it's going to happen in Indianapolis
this coming weekend it happens almost
every time in a big game and against
against Iowa against Iowa Michigan had a
phantom facemask penalty called on it
that allow to Iowa better field position
for the game-winning field goal but
again don't put yourself in that
position by fumbling the opening kickoff
or throwing interceptions or turning the
ball over or we're being in a fish
in other parts of the game you you open
yourself up to that and you know that's
that's where things currently stand i
wish my my school was not involved in
this to Los morass I wish they would be
in a much better position and
unfortunately they're not right now yes
i'm watching there's no doubt my mind
michigan feels like the better team they
just made mistakes and it didn't come
down to penalties you know the spot I
didn't like for JT Barrett but you know
hard balls got to keep his composure
there you know you can't get flagged for
throwing your clipboard even though it
seems very trivial yeah I mean look I
mean you even were marked what letting
about urban meyer's uh uh you know
cheerlead you know he's thrown here yeah
but I want to see antics because it's
not he's into it yeah and and
everybody's into it I mean there's a
reason why 17 million people tuned in
middle of an afternoon here you know
because they're watching how much it
matters to everybody involved and and so
you know to flag that sort of thing is
ridiculous and but but that's not really
what you know that's not really what
costume I'm I really don't want to come
across as I'm making excuses there's
with the officiating but there's always
an issue with it always III can even
show you the text that I did exchange
with two of my friends from college
saying you know it's common it's common
and I think it's going to come in the
form of a pass interference penalty on a
long down and distance on third down and
it two seconds later I'm like
Nostradamus it happened does anybody cry
in the arm I did scare Cooper over the
spot of the football I'll see you yelled
I did yeah I did but after that though
it was a teachable moment after that it
was a teachable moment your wife was
teaching you know
is that all the time what yeah you know
what I mean so bottom line is this way
too many mistakes they had the game they
had the game in many different ways not
sewn up but but in their control and
couldn't close it and you know uh but
but I will say this to dan you know I've
spent ten years prior to Harbaugh I
guess after the one versus two game
things kind of changed with the
Appalachian State loss and then Lloyd
Carr going leaving the rich rod and
Brady Hoke and then there were just so
many losses that were so brutal and I
would just look at games like that
Saturday with other teams playing in
them saying you know I wish my team
would be playing in something that
mattered so much with so much on the
line and now it's happening and I
absolutely take great solace in that but
this one really really hurts he's rich
eisen from the NFL network if we had a
final four in the NFL and you could take
just the four best teams it doesn't have
to be too from the n fe NM see two from
the AFC right new england oakland and
alice i would i would take dallas in
seattle i will you would takes you yes I
definitely would yeah it's just weird
team they've gone three games without an
offensive touchdown they guy I know
roughed up you know the ampa I know the
the Russell Wilson offense sometimes
disappears at the most head-scratching
times but still there battle-tested
they're really great on defense they
really are they played that game
yesterday gave up a couple of early
touchdowns to Mike Evans and essentially
wiped him out from there on in and the
offense been more efficient and put
points on the board they would have won
that game too and tamp is clearly a hot
team right now I like Seattle a lot
Dallas is absolutely the best team but
if there's TV 12 was the greatest
equalizer of all that's sitting there in
New England and I like the raiders a lot
you know yesterday we can make a lot of
Derek Carr and him going out and now it
switched the momentum around but
Khalil Mack was a guy who owned that
game form yesterday and he could be that
von miller type coming around the edge
that gives New England issues when it
should should they meet on the January
day but i would take those four teams
yeah we've been talking about that
trying to figure this out you know the
chiefs and Broncos finished last night I
I didn't agree with going with the kick
only from the perspective of if you're
going to go for a 65-yard er why not run
the ball on the previous down and run
some clock just in case you don't miss
it you can't give Kansas City any
opportunity here and that that was the
only thing that I weighed you know it's
38 degrees you're kicking he'd never
kicked any five yards farther than
anything he'd ever made and I don't care
if you're making them in pregame I've
seen guys make them in pregame all the
time and they get to a game and it's
different I I disagree with it your
thoughts in the moment on that case I I
loved it I thought it was great you know
you're punting you're basically telling
everybody let's play for the tie and go
home um and and in the long run you know
that it that would be the big the big
boy approached just to say that I'm
looking at the long run picture and and
they'd be sitting there at six in the
standings right now in front of Miami
instead of seven but you know uh that
was von Miller in that defense that was
making sure Alec Smith could hardly move
the ball unbelievable um all night long
so I'm thinking I'm gonna give my guy a
chance to win but you're right at making
sure that they uh either tie or don't
win as opposed to either tie or lose
well you can kick it but just run the
football to run some I make sense and
even if you do that you're you're making
Andy Reid burn as [ __ ] about which they
need it yes they needed him so yeah I'd
agree with you on that front he said in
terms of Michigan in terms of by the way
Michigan being the better team yeah the
issue is one of the top four teams the
issue is is what's the criteria if the
criteria is win-loss Michigan is not one
of the best teams top four teams they're
not they're not and and one-loss teams
should get the opportunity to go before
to Los team but if you're sitting here
saying what is the criteria is the
criteria having a team that's playing
hot
if that's the case then Michigan is not
one of those teams either having lost
through the last three if you are
looking at a game like Saturday and
saying I want one of those for the
national championship to be one of the
semi-final teams you want something that
intense that closely contested then
maybe you take the two teams that
actually just played it and play it
again see how that goes no I don't know
if that's a criteria if it isn't then
then Michigan is not one of the top four
teams in the country who's on the
program uh mooch Steve Mariucci Chris
long who is the closer yeah of the
Patriots yesterday and the Patriots are
playing his former team in the Rams
coming up this week so it should be an
interesting chat with him and us I was
hoping it would be a much cheerier chat
we've got Michigan royalty of NCIS Mark
Harmon the son of oh good thom hartmann
here would have been much nicer result
would have been a much nicer
conversation but i'm looking forward to
chatting with him anyway so be good
times with Mark Harmon here of NCIS yeah
but mark only cares about you UCLA
didn't care about Michigan I don't know
though I mean when when Devin Gardner
was given his dad's number you know he
was part of the process of discussing it
I mean he's he's dope he's still
somewhat involved in the maize and blue
but you're right he's he's a brewing
keep your head up keep it thanks DP and
I won't call you Michigan apologist even
though it sounded like a Michigan Apollo
she's been here all night did we border
knows it again I said we made the
mistakes that that 18 wheels are we okay
but that sounds like you're still a
Michigan apologies on the wrong with
being a Michigan apologist but I'm not
apologizing what am i apologizing for
for playing one of the classic games for
my school playing one of the classic
games they ok then it it made too many
mistakes Michigan and loyalists tells
that okay I'll take it could hold it all
right have a good show yeah you bet
that's rich eisen the Dan Patrick show
weekday mornings on audience
you